Being here with tonight's honorees, reflecting on their contributions,...
...I'm reminded of a Supreme Court opinion by the great Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes.
In a case argued before the Court in 1926,...
...the majority ruled that the state of New York...
...couldn't regulate the price of theater tickets because in the opinion of the majority,...
...the theater was not a public necessity.
They argued in effect that the experience of attending the theater was superfluous.
And this is what Justice Holmes had to say.
"Too many people," he wrote in his dissent...
...let me start that over.
"To many people, the superfluous..." it's this lip.
It's hard to say.
You try it when you've had 12 stitches.
"The superfluous." Thank you.
Alright.
"To many people the superfluous is necessary."
"The theater is necessary. Dance is necessary."
"Song is necessary. The arts are necessary."
"They are a necessary part of our lives."
The men and women here tonight embody that idea.
Their work has enriched our lives. It's inspired us to greatness.
And tonight, it is my honor to offer them the appreciation of a grateful nation.
Thank you very much, all five of you. God bless you. Thank you.